[Applaudissements]
direction le sud de l'île à petite-île
plus précisément rude et encore
c'est ici sur cette exploitation
agricole que didier son rsa créé il ya
neuf ans maintenant la ferme aubergines
alors ici une relation exploitation de à
l'hectare 4 rebonds avec une partie en a
qui colle donc c'est un candidat chez et
puis ben là où nous les notions une
partie on est partis élevage et on
agrotourisme son activités
agrotouristiques s'est arrêté pendant
trois mois pour respecter les
contraintes sanitaires du confinement
liés à l'épidémie de kobe 19 une crise
économique et sociale qui impacte et
tout l'environnement de cette ferme
auberge
tu connais un petit peu sur un peu
d'économie et après à ranger au niveau
de forme en léger et après c'était
surtout d'essayer la rangée avec les
fournisseurs avec les banques pour
pouvoir décaler un peu tout ça mais quoi
qu'il en soit il ya environ pour
forcément les choses parce que dell a
quand même se troue existants mais vaut
tenir en tout cas pendant ce temps là
c'était de décaler de pouvoir décaler
vers les vallées les échéances valeur
pour permettre la reprise d'activité de
ces exploitations agrotouristique le
département accorde une subvention de
1500 euros par exploitation
une centaine de structures est
directement prise en charge ce avec
l'appui permettent au moins de
participer un petit peu acheter des
aliments pour les pour les animaux pour
maintenir entre temps bagneux c'était
principalement sain pour skako
télécharger tout qui ont été décalés
donc c'était principalement pour aider
au niveau de l'alimentation des animaux
avec les nouvelles mesures de
déconfinement effective le 2 juin
dernier didier torres a repris son
activité de ferme auberges avec ses
premiers clients et espère que le plus
dur de la crise est maintenant derrière
lui
[Musique]